[Musique]
vous devez adopter la mentalité d'un
flic de rue irlandais le monde est un mauvais
endroit les gens sont des crétins paresseux les minorités
sont des criminels le sexe est malade mais
intéressant demandez-vous ce qui
effrayerait ma grand-mère ou énerverait mon
grand-père et c'est une histoire de Fox Oh
les femmes sont partout bien laissez-les jouer au
golf et au tennis maintenant vous avez chargé au
téléphone parce que vous m'avez appelé une jupe oui
ouais l'attitude hors caméra était encore pire
vous êtes un homme qui déteste apprendre à vous entendre
avec les garçons vous êtes sexy mais vous '  re
trop de travail j'ai toute une liste nous allons d'
autres femmes se présenter vous avez peut-être
entendu dire qu'il y avait une poussière impliquant
votre serviteur et le candidat à la présidence
Donald Trump c'était du sang qui sortait de
ses yeux du sang qui sortait d'elle
partout où Dieu l'a fait  il vient de m'accuser de
colère les hommes tendent attendre est-ce que je vais être
l'histoire ouais non je vais être l'histoire
non personne ne s'arrête pour regarder à cause d'
un conflit ils arrêtent de regarder quand il
n'y en a pas un je veux te convaincre que
j'appartiens  à l'antenne  m.  Ailes, je pense que je
serais phénoménal sur votre réseau Je
pourrais vous arracher et vous déplacer en
tête de file mais j'ai besoin de savoir
que vous êtes loyal J'ai besoin que vous trouviez un
moyen de le prouver même si je Ron  vient d'
avoir ce bloc de porte dans son bureau
quelqu'un doit parler quelqu'un doit se
faire écraser La star de FoxNews, Gretchen Carlson, a
largué un gros obus à la bombe aujourd'hui, qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait, cela pourrait tuer Fox News, nous avons
besoin de tout le monde sur l'observateur de l'équipe,
mettez-le sur ces  sont à la fin des temps,
tu comprends que je dois être au-dessus de ce
droit et tu sais que tout le pays
parle de tes règles en ce moment
[Musique]
ma
chérie c'est une île de sécurité et de vérité
prête à partir en guerre
vous